foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will learn about how to obtain or how to
print current date using SQL but before
we begin let me tell you guys that we
have daily updates on multiple
Technologies if you're a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
Trends then consider getting subscribed
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit that Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply gone now without
further Ado let's get started with our
one point agenda that is how to print or
how to obtain current date in SQL now
the syntax is really simple we have two
different commands to do that we can
just type in select get date or we can
just type in select current date or Cur
date so these particular commands or
functions will fetch us the current date
in SQL now to execute these commands
let's get back to the Practical mode
which can be a SQL workbench so now we
are on the SQL workbench let's login
there you go so we have both the
commands let's try to execute them
don't enter and there you go so we have
the current date so that's how you can
fetch current date using get date
function or the current date function in
SQL with that we have come to an end of
this session on how to fetch or how to
print the current date using SQL and if
you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session or if
you require the resources that we use in
this session then do let us know in the
comment section below and RTM of experts
will be more than happy to reserve all
your queries at the earliest until next
time thank you stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
foreign